okay for people joining this live stream
we are doing a review of incremental
language development
for language most of this some of this
might still be
making it into version 12.3 which is
coming up
uh other things will be for the future
okay rule plot
right so we have mano with us to discuss
this and
if we can go to the documentation page
yep do i need to update documentation or
is it
fairly uh we implemented this yesterday
if you have
updated since yesterday should be enough
i would assume i have
hey no road plot okay
okay yeah so the first thing
is that now there will be this new
notation
for uh and underdetermined
or non-deterministic turing machines
and i just right i i saw typo
immediately it should be turing machine
rather than turing right so it needs to
know that for turmeric
for a cellular automaton by the way we
can also have underdetermined and
over-determined
cases and i don't know whether whether
it objects to those
i can check and yeah why don't you check
that yeah
um i mean for i think the reason it
needs to know for a turing machine is
because of the
the head oh no it needs to know for a
cellular automaton as well because of
the color
levels
okay okay we can do it but do we need to
explain here what we mean by
underspecified and non-deterministic
so for for example this is something
that manu explained to me i
didn't know before yes yes we should um
um
um
okay
i think my main confusion was that i
would have expected s and k to be in the
spec
but somehow we need some sort of
embedding into a larger set
all right let's just say touring yeah
it's a typo right it's a type it should
be
machine yeah
oh gosh why is it doing that that's
wrong yeah
sorry we can fix that later okay all
right okay
the question is why isn't it in turing
machines a good
for question machine it doesn't really
matter right because it just generates
the result of the evolution
but s and k only matter for when you're
rendering the
visuals
but we could still give it as an
advisory thing in the turing machine
how would that work
well the case okay so we've got nsk
what's this why isn't this a reasonable
way to do it
do you see i don't know why that was
futurized
right because then it's directly
analogous to
nsk where we are giving the snk
right okay i can make sure this case
works
i think that's what we should do rather
than this case i i'm sorry to say
i think we goofed here i think this is
ugly because this
this requires us to be and we can
you don't have to take this out but i
don't think we should document this
i think this is the right way to
document it
okay so that rule is representing what
we call here spec
that is correct yes but no no the spec
because in this case right
we could say
turing machine
1507 comma two two
okay and that is okay so there's a rule
plot of that
okay now what we're proposing is
that in here we'd be able to give
the whole you know blah blah blah blah
et cetera et cetera et cetera and then
this would give
the um um
right i think the correct thing is
mashima explicit rule given
um
okay we could say here um
um
if the rule
um a particular rule um
if a rule has multiple specifications
for
a given configuration
the first one turing machine
will use the first one listed
okay so that's dealing with the the okay
um um
where do we say that rule plot shows the
the results
say um
the form rule
s k
can be used to specify
um multi-way
non-deterministic
and other
turing machines with
in which there is not
necessarily a single
case in the rule for a given
configuration
um
i think this is how we should do it
does that seem okay to you guys yep
makes sense yep
so we added some examples in the rule
plot
in scope section okay
that's good let's see but i think that
these should be changed to the new form
right um
i think in for example if you look at
turing machine at the end of
system evolution to the machine or the
two
at the very end
so those cases are non-deterministic and
underspecified
okay i think will be useful to give
so evolutions are in the further in the
other section further
turing machine okay the under specified
one will work fine the overspecified one
will just pick the first one right
i know yeah yeah it'll just uh
depend on the order of the rules yeah
okay i think this is good and um
yeah okay we can unfuturize this
uh how do we do this 12 3 okay
um explicit rule
um
somewhere we should document the fact
that for a touring machine what we
should say here
um
in the turing machine case
can be used to specify
a turing machine
in which
that is assumed to have s states
in which
not every
there's not a single case
oh gosh in which um
let me see uh specified turn machine
in which the behavior is not uniquely
given for all
sk configurations okay
which rule does not uniquely specify
transformation
for all 2sk cases
for each for each
is it 2sk or sk
it's a sky thank you
i think that's right
but which nevertheless will be rendered
but which nevertheless
okay
okay
by the way i don't know whether plot
theme has been developed any further for
this
what's this picture let's see yeah
that's the second point
where to put that illustration
ethan the livestream is commenting the
little arrows and turing machine cells
are not
centered centroid should be pinned
why are we saying that this little
circle it's like a
it's like a dial
i don't think that's wrong
um
do we need this picture
perhaps not right and it was there and
we just wanted to know whether
i'm not i'm not i have no particular i
mean i think it's
it's like you see it you do it that's
what we need to
to have happen um
this is an unbelievably complicated
turing machine let's let's let's
skip that and put it lower down or
something because we need to get to
these non-deterministic ones because
that's
far from obvious
i don't even understand how this one
works this is assuming
you've got to be able to say
i think we have an evolution for that
one in the next section
so perhaps that's clear okay
all right this seems reasonable
okay let's move on yes so the the the
second point you already addressed and
the third
was just uh single state cases yes i
think a drop a dot
just a lot i think so i think that's
what i did in the multi way turing
machine
document we went back and forth a bit
but i can make the
dot happen what did i do in the end
didn't i do a dot in the end
you used a dot in uh i think like one
case
but for most of them it was the teardrop
pump should we be able to select between
those
well i guess you can by just saying it's
a two-state turing machine
yeah so we might want to make some
comment that the one state i mean we do
it and then we'll make a comment later
the one state case does that um
one day we should probably have some
plot themes for
even cellular automata i don't know
whether we have those for different
color schemes and so on
do we have those
not clear i'll take a look
okay i will
okay okay so i think that we don't need
manu anymore
okay i mean okay great okay
thanks mano thank you bye okay
so this is a question that has appeared
while working on lexicographic order
on associations and so let me just let
me just do the update so i don't
forget yep um okay lexicographic order
and associations
yes so the first thing i should say here
is that there are two different
questions here and the important one is
the second one so one question
is order inside one association
and the other question is the how to
order a list of associations
so what we are interested today is the
second question
right so this key sort
right so this is order for one
association i just wanted to say that
for one association we can sort by
values or by keys for example here we
have
translations from spanish to english so
we can say
sort the values using english or sorry
the keys using spanish
so that's great but we don't have a way
of
sorting by both at the same time which
is the question that's going to appear
now
so when we have a list of associations
in general
in in in the system with canonical order
is short legs
the first thing it looks is is length
but for associations
it's lexicographic so it's sorting by
looking at keys and then values
not using the length thing not using the
length so for example you see how
in this first order even though the
first one is longer than the second one
it
still prefers the first one because the
first why did we do that
so after thinking about this i think
this is good for example for
for data set lists of associations
because then things get sorted by their
keys
which feels natural there so this might
have been
but the truth is that i haven't realized
this after so many years this has been
implemented since 2014
so i don't think this is something we
should change lightly
but now that we know that order itself
is lexicographic
somehow lexicographic order feels
as if it should follow what order does
already because it's already
lexicographic okay so what's the
question here
yeah so the question is that last week
we had said okay let's lexicographic
order
sort by values but what we see is order
is lexicographic by keys so what i'm
suggesting now is that we follow the
same thing so that order and
lexicographic order are consistent well
another way to put it would be
why would we have that happen because
then lex graphic order isn't doing
anything different from order
in other words we might as well have
both functionalities available
i see what you mean so we ignore keys
and basically pretend it's positional
i think that will be the best thing to
do because given that order
is doing lexical graphic by keys that
functionality is already available
i think in terms of what we passed to p
here i have to believe it's this
well if we decide to go by values it
will we would be passing just three and
two
and because we wouldn't care about it i
see i see i see i see
in fact the problem is that because
order is passing both
internally effectively the question is
if we wanted to generalize that case we
would have to pass this purse which
which is a non-standard thing to do
but if we go for values only then the
problem is solved
i think that's what we should do i think
likes a
graphic order then should be applied to
values as which is kind of the central
dogma of associations anyway
right that was the argument last week
before we had realized this
difference right i think that's okay i
think we should document the difference
but i think it's okay
okay uh any comment um um danny um
no i think uh so so basically when we
have
two associations we we extract their
values and work from there
is what it sounds like exactly you were
thinking of of using normal to extract
the key value pairs it would be just
destructive values
okay um there's still the issue of
if i remember correctly there was just
an outrageous problem with order
involved with associations
yeah i think that was a small back for
constantine to to consider
uh in in order of associations okay but
if that's done i assume that what i'll
be doing with lexicographic
order will not in any way um
interfere with that no i don't think so
it's just that
you have to use values yeah okay fine
okay okay
um yeah okay well that's all that was
quicker than i thought
so we reviewed these ones last week
okay so so let's go on with the ones we
haven't reviewed
exactly yep and we have rick with us to
discuss this today
toggle button what is this
okay what is this doing
i guess every time that you click that's
the next
some sort of cyclic
for the comment it's not something we're
suggesting as its own function it's
something that
might be considered
as part of button or toggler
if i can understand what it does
i think it was most similar to toddler
which we already have
and that could possibly be extended to
support this
i think we should ask somebody like lou
what they think because i'm i'm not
why did did you write this and if so
what was it useful for
how's michael okay um
i have to admit that that my use of
toddler is hardly
large
okay so toggler
i see it's just doing values but here
this is taking an action
i think we should ask lou i'm i'm i
don't have i'm not i mean
there is the fourth usage on toddler
is similar i think the main benefit of
this over togglers
it delays the evaluation when you click
yes which i don't think toggler can do
that right and i think button
does stuff like that yeah
okay so this gets shipped
to lose a question i think so
i mean to me this is more of a button
story
and you know the fact the button doesn't
take
its functionality
i mean you know the fact that button has
a label and an action like that
this is like a multi button that has a
list of delayed rules to create its
actions
if that makes sense so that's the key
thing it seems to me here
okay i'm gonna let you discuss that
we have a a an interrupt from sander
here
asking that we look at variants around
and other such things
the question is is there a way to get
all
i mean in other words if these numbers
could be turned into a round numbers
then we could have every function work
on this couldn't we
or am i wrong um variance around so
do a round no do do just a round of that
list i'm not sure understand what this
function is to
what is that doing so this is taking the
mean and estimating of
uh deviation
what's the difference is not a mean
around the mean around
is it i mean the mean is the same one
but the error is
smaller so mean around is
estimating the mean and the uncertainty
of the mean
not the deviation of the distribution so
it is
what i i didn't know that the work this
way i should have been using this
so this i mean if you imagine that there
is a gaussian
so this is estimating the width of the
gaussian while the second one is
estimating
the position of the maximum of the width
of the evolution sorry
gosh i should have been using that first
one a zillion times
right so so around the offer of a
statistical distribution returns
there the the the mean
and the standard deviation so this
follows the idea that
a list of numbers is a discrete uh
statistical distribution
right so sandra is commenting um
uh that this variance around
returns the error of the variance yes
but so i mean my question would be
okay so so if i'm not mistaken i mean
there's one approach would be to say
empirical distribution
let me just understand whether this is
doing what i think it's doing
okay so there's an empirical
distribution there and then we say
um mean of that
okay that's your 1.97 and if i then say
standard deviation of that right
no no i'm confused no no that's the 0.6
of the first one
so i see right so that's exactly what
the first one is doing if
you do um maybe you do input form of out
tank
i'd like to point out that we've got
rick here and we're off on
something of a tangent outside of the
scope of this meeting
okay we're going to continue with this
tangent for a little bit
the um
so what's your point jose i was
expecting the 0.58 to be
0 53
i have to investigate why there is a
difference
so some probably empirical distribution
has
done something that has slightly changed
that number
so my point is that in the same way that
we can assign an error to the 1.97
we could also assign an error to the
0.58
which i think is what this requires but
at the 0.34
that i don't understand where it's
coming from
okay but in general
mean around is an estimate of the mean
of that thing okay but so i could
equally well
estimate the ketosis of that thing
couldn't i
yes yes and and it would probably also
have an error
and the standard deviation so so
imagine for example that this
distribution takes more and more and
more numbers
the 0.6 will stay constant in a round
but the min around will get smaller and
smaller
in in the second number because you will
be able to estimate that
i understand but so so you know what we
might want is some kind of i mean this
isn't a good word but
estimate around kurtosis
and then data something like that i
don't know what what
does that does that make sense i mean so
i think what we should have
because there are some very many things
we can compute is on our round value and
then we start asking for many properties
okay but i mean i think what's going to
be useful is because it is a very
you know it's a very definite thing we
can compute the ketosis we don't need to
get in we need a derivative of the
ketosis don't we to be able to get this
this error is that not correct
it's just a formula there i mean all
these estimators have
alight alight formulas okay but we but i
mean the question is can i put an
arbitrary function in here
can that does that not work
that i don't know okay
why don't we think about that question
because that seems like it's the general
case
um
it's a function that takes the list as
an argument
and
you know it's
okay let's see so so sandra is
commenting that's probably an n
versus n minus one right um
yeah that's probably why this
um
sandra is saying it's not that easy
because the propagation of the errors
the formulas get more and more
complicated
um as as you get
higher and higher moments basically of
the distribution
right but as long as it is a moment
i think it's computable but the general
functions
that that's even that that's what i
don't know
because then we enter the the transform
distribution general case and that's
very hard
yes
well the question is what packaging
could we give
for
you know for other things like this
what's the right way to do packaging
okay it's a separate discussion but i
think this is a good
it's a good thing to raise let's let's
keep going down
the list here non-convex hull well i
have to say i've definitely used this um
i think it's a very nice function
actually yeah i think it's very useful
somebody mean to turn the camera on
no okay um
the um uh how would it fit into other
things that we have
do we have somebody from computational
geometry here
uh you know i think so i'll say it might
fit in a bit with regions
since it's a way of measuring them
yes yes so this operation there is
something called alpha
alpha shapes i think it's called which
computes this
yeah it looks like the alpha complex so
it's a subset of the delaney
triangulation
okay but but the thing that i mean
we got to have somebody from the group
that works on region stuff because i
mean i
this seems like a very good function and
you know right now
they have discretized region but that's
a different thing
um i'm not sure the name here is it's a
little weird
okay so if i take those points
and i say oh great okay whatever
and i say convex hull
mesh of that okay i get this
okay and this thing here
um
um sandra is saying should non-convex
hull must be an option to convex
mesh it seems a little weird to do that
um because it says convex hull it really
isn't a convex hull i mean that is
profoundly not a convex hull
um this function is a function we want
so there's a question for the
computational geometry team to figure
out how best to do it
it might be a meshing function but it's
definitely not
something related or part or should be
assumed by convex hull meshing
yeah i agree it's um
yeah and this requires additional
parameters to specify
i mean this is a very clear case but if
the points are not so
clearly grouped together in a clear
region then it's very difficult
right so for the computational geometry
team
definition data
what is this oh this is this a better
form of question
mark this is basically
a pretty packaged version of the
language backtick extended full
definition
yeah that's not what i'm asking i'm
asking
right now if i give one of these
definitions and i say question mark f
i get something right
yeah okay what is the how does this
relate to that
the question mark f is just like a
display thing
this will actually package up all the
definitions into
a blob like that that you can you
use later in other sessions
so i see so not a side effect
of printing okay so what this is doing
is packaging up down values and things
like that
how do i then rehydrate them
so i defined it as a
up values on it so if you look a little
bit further down get of data
we'll reload those definitions including
the dependencies
so this is this is an interesting thing
this is interesting i mean so this is
basically
a micro version of save
is that correct i mean it's kind of a
it's an interesting idea
i mean it's sort of like i can eyes it's
a version of
this is a way of essentially creating an
in-notebook
saved object correct
yeah that's an interesting idea i mean
it's a
it's an idea that's relevant okay let me
think about this for a second
i mean i could also think about this as
an iconized version of a bunch of
definitions
but this is a nice clean way to do it
there's a good idea
i'm not sure i like the name but it's a
good idea it could also be
uh an extension to iconize maybe iconize
could have
include definitions as an option and
just automatically do this stuff
well yes but i can eyes
um oh by the way sandra is commenting on
on non-convex whole mesh
that it potentially a second argument to
convex whole mesh conceivably
we can raise that with the but the
computational geometry people
but okay so so you know this is
something we should have thought of
before
so i can eyes which is also something we
should have thought of many years before
he thought of it
um okay let's let's run through what
this really is
so i can eyes is a displayed thing
let's say range of 10.
now i click that i say i can eyes
and i get that and it really is
you know just a way of not having to see
all of that stuff
now what you're saying your thing is
doing here
is i need to remember to remove that
definition but anyway
uh okay so if i just say data of
f why is this taking so long okay
an f could depend on g yeah if you
if you define g it would say two symbols
in there
okay this is an interesting thing
um let me just think so so what is now
the relation between
information of data and information of f
i think information of f is just giving
the f direct stuff
not the g
right i see that that's not giving the
that's not giving the sub dependencies
now presumably information of percent
22.
well okay so it's giving a little bit
more stuff it's saying that it's both
got both
f and g inside it
actually this is really interesting i
mean so what this is allowing one to do
is to have essentially a package in a
notebook
yeah exactly
um i think connor should look at this in
connection with the paclet stuff
but this and also in connection with the
what he's referring to is the new new
package format
um
let me think about that for a second
okay so you have this i mean to me
it's an interesting thing to be able to
yeah um
okay i'm still thinking for a second the
this
so it's also an alternative to
initialization cells
yeah i really like this i mean i think
this is a really good idea i
i think it needs a little bit more
development why don't we get connor to
think about it and maybe you can talk to
connor
in the context of the new new package
format
sure yeah i couldn't but it seems like a
really good idea
although i don't i'm not sure how it
would relate to package format because
this is
like if you did input form of that
definition data thing it's
like i'm aware i'm aware i know but i
mean it will be
the the thing is i mean it has nothing
no direct package stuff inside it
i just think conceptually this is like a
package packaged into a notebook if you
understand what i'm saying
yeah because mostly
you know when we think about a package
see what what this is
you know i can imagine right being able
to take
if i take your average oops your average
um uh
why is this so slow what's going on
there okay so imagine i have something
from here
i can imagine wanting to take that whole
notebook
and say package package that
package so to speak into one of these
blobs
right because i want to include it i
mean this is something we've not been
able to do
but it's a very useful thing it's like
iconizing the definitions in an
initialization
a bunch of initialization cells or a
package file
see what i'm saying yeah so instead of
having this
hanging out of my file system somewhere
it's just in the notebook but it's in
the notebook in a form that isn't
you know that isn't particularly ugly
i'm not copying and i could imagine
a version of your blob i suppose
yeah it's an interesting question could
your blob actually refer to
an external
i mean it could have something where it
says go look in this place but if you
can't find an updated version here
or if you can't find that place go back
and use these definitions i'm using here
but this is the use case that i can
imagine here which is actually a very
useful use case which i should have
thought of
years ago which is as i say packaging a
package so you can put it in a notebook
does that make sense yeah and for what
you're saying about
checking a file that would be useful for
example if like you didn't currently
have an internet connection
and normally it would like load
definitions from some remote file or
something but if it's not available then
use the bundled stuff yep
yeah i think this is a this is a winning
idea so
talk to connor a bit about it because i
think it relates to the new package
format a bit
um because i can imagine something where
i it also relates to paclets because you
can take
you could imagine a local version of a
paclet
that is one of these blobs see what i'm
saying
where the whole packlet is inside your
notebook and where perhaps
it you know it refers to the paclet
but can always fall back on what is in
the notebook so to speak
so precisely it would take a context or
perhaps a list of functions
rather than just a single function
exactly yes
and i mean this is this is like
i mean in some weird sense it's like
save blob
in the same sense that import string
or export string exports not
to by the way by the way here's another
idea related to this
so you know that we have this notion of
imported objects
i wonder whether export string should be
generalized
to also have the notion of i've exported
it to this
blob which i can then move around
and re-import if i want to i mean i
guess i guess that's essentially what
export string and export byte array do
export byte array is probably the
closest to what i'm talking about there
yeah that's what i why i typically use
import or export bite array over string
because
right you can store anything and and in
fact it does essentially a blobbery
there because it just you know the byte
array is shown as a blob
i think this is a really good idea rick
so i mean that
can we bring this back another one of
these meetings and
you know talk to connor and so on and
see what you can figure out here
yeah i'll talk to him about it took me a
little while to understand what the heck
this thing was
um okay corolla
corello graham these are famous
i mean this is really for um
i mean this is really like spectrogram
it's in that family isn't it
anybody want to comment on that i think
it is i'm not positive
okay so i mean to me this goes to shoddy
seems like a reasonable thing to me and
it probably has a bunch of options like
spectrogram has a bunch of options
make sense yes well
um it does accept i'm wondering if it
actually goes to gaucher's group
or some combination uh possibly yes
somewhere between charity and gosh i
don't know which whether whether it
counts as
signal processing or statistics okay
if you're talking geographically that
would put it in bulgaria i think
sorry what
never mind yeah but they're both in the
u.s right
so what else they are okay that's i
think chicago and just champagne so
uh yeah right okay fine so that puts it
in kankakee
exactly yeah um
okay uh hex string to reel
the author in that particular meeting
why did you danny why did you write this
um i wrote it because i i did not
suggest that it be promoted i wrote it
because
it was requested on on wolfram community
somebody asked how to do this and once i
did it i thought it would make a decent
submission
yeah but but i mean i'm trying to
understand the more general case of this
um well i mean
what it is is an attempt to
get computer arithmetic to work
correctly round tripping
between our numbers and uh what you know
your standard uh ieee doubles
well yeah if anybody uses hex string
versions i mean
when when you put i mean when you write
a literal in a c
program in modern times in ancient times
they used to be i mean by ancient i mean
40 years ago
there used to be various ways to
indicate
you know mantissa exponent and so on
what do you do in modern times can you
do it this way in modern times
as a hex string yeah um i think i see
that in
see occasionally i think
well that's the question is is the right
now
we have the ability to encode as hex
integers basically right what you're
saying here
i mean we we have um uh you know base 64
encoding and things like this
right yes so the issue is if you have a
line triple e
number how do you you know how does that
work with respect to those encodings
yeah i mean i assume that mark or
somebody would know that i think we
should ask
this seems like the kind of thing we
should have but i don't understand how
it should relate to things like
you know basin code for example
by the way what is this is this some
reason i don't know the answer to that i
mean
i just want to report the bug that the
the the
bottom of this raft is missing at this
i magnification it okay um
sorry go ahead no i was i was trying to
make sure i got the emulation
of computer arithmetic correct to the
last bit to the best of my ability
was the point um whether whether i did
or not i don't know
and okay so mark is a sort of world
expert on this stuff why don't we ask
him
and ask whether there is a more general
category of
round-tripping you know machine numbers
through hex and so on would this be
something to extend from digits
so that can already take a hex string
but it's just for integers
that's a good point yes the answer would
be yes
yeah with some kind of ieee you know i
could imagine something like this from
digits
of this thing i mean if i if i give that
as a hex string right now i'm from
digits
i assume what will it do
okay it assumed that was a hexadecimal
thing
right yeah i think the it's implied the
second argument is 16.
so maybe it could be a third argument
saying like what type of number
well it could be ieee for example here
that makes good sense to me
ask mark makes sense to me
um can we move on yeah sure
what do you what are you pausing about i
never get
answers when i ask questions
i'm rolling my eyes what can i say
i don't expect to get an answer back
when i ask
that's depressing um
then i think devon here
is responsible for going chasing it okay
go through my chasing infrastructure if
necessary
yeah okay if it doesn't involve me the
likelihood goes up
wow you sound as unpopular as i feel
[Laughter]
not always that way um
anyway
uh by the way sandra is commenting about
uh supporting around and fit linear
model fit and so on
yes it is an in progress but it is as
you as you suspect quite difficult
and it probably is going to be helped by
the fact that around now uses the
compiler
and will be dramatically faster in
version 12.3
right jose yes yes um i'm hoping
i mean the work of extending it through
the statistics functionality is hard
because the statistics functionality is
very large
right but that's a gaucher project
that's not your project
exactly yeah okay replace
all unheld and i need to run off for
them out here
um
uh look there's a whole class
i don't know i never know what that
means i wish people would actually put
their names there and somehow
things that i wrote seem to not have my
name on which is just fine
but i think this is something in the
developer context and nobody knows
oh i see i see it's long lost yeah this
might be from general utilities
okay well whatever um
an attempt to transform that would be
normally be evaluated
um
i don't know what this is but there's a
whole class look
there's two categories of thing that i'm
keen to look at i want to
three categories uh manipulating
um code in held form
dealing with the tracing of the
execution of code and
tracing structures and causal graphs
related to tracing structures
and the third is multi-way and
non-deterministic computation
and those three things are all kind of
heavy lifting language design
which once 12.3 is out of the way i
think we could try and tackle a bit of
um this i think is in that category is
in that
gaggle of stuff related to held code
cop you know health code manipulation i
think we need to
treat it um
in that collection just curious what
this is and i really need to go
um in fact i'm supposed to be doing
another live stream
at the at the 30 minutes past the hour
about completely different topic always
good to be
it's um a business and innovation q a
um okay
what is this doing
oh i see this is for another time
we need to talk about this another time
it's going to take me a moment to
understand what the
what the idea is here um
well there's a lot of good functions in
here this is great
what fraction just to give me some sense
um how many functions
are have you picked out uh
from the function repository to look at
here and how does it relate to the total
number that are in there
i i think what we're looking at is about
a 40
um
you know that are making their way into
this meeting
which is more than i would would have
wanted but i i don't know if that's good
or bad or if we should be tamping down
harder or not
right curious to get feedback on that
um this is also selected by dates if i
understand correctly right
yeah yeah we're going by chronology um
to
for a number of reasons mostly related
to sanity
um but i don't anticipate that the
percentage will change by too much
certainly not in any rapid way you mean
40
of functions in the function repository
we are considering yeah
yeah so from the month of february of
2019
i think we got about 40 so how many are
in this notebook total um that
that was sent to you i don't know i
think it's uh
more than it might be i mean
let me not write the code to find out
they can do a notebook report
um so
they are sorted by rank so perhaps it's
just a matter of
selecting some rank here
i see um
oh but why don't we just use that
technology those are subsections right
looks like
66 roughly minus a few
okay so um that's actually closer to 50
percent of the total i think they were
around 140.
okay well i think it's going to go down
because i think what you know it got to
be more specialized i think
i'm not sure um yeah
i i expect it will drop modestly
um i don't expect much unless we
um all right well look the things we're
seeing here
are worth seeing so happy okay
i mean you know if we were going through
here and we were rejecting them and
saying
well that's amusing but it's too weird
then it's different story we're not
saying that we keep on saying this is
interesting we should try and look at it
putting it here or there
okay then we'll keep doing what we're
doing with the reviews
i think it's worthwhile sounds good all
right
well uh thanks a lot guys to be
continued next time
thanks to folks on live stream too